des cas qui augmente également en france
et une vaccination qui ralentit le
gouvernement n'exclut pas de rendre
obligatoire la troisième dose la
première lecture du projet de loi de
vigilance sanitaire qui se poursuit
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale le
projet de loi prévoit notamment de
prolonger les usages du passé ni terre
jusqu'en juillet 2022 pour plus de
précision va tout de suite retrouvé
justement devant l'assemblée nationale
estelle farges
[Musique]
bonjour estelle on va faire le point sur
ce pas salutaire qui est à l'étude à
l'assemblée nationale avec le ministre
de la santé qui a appelé à rester
vigilant
exactement magali ne pas nous désarmer
quand bien même le virus montrerait des
signes de faiblesse ce sont elles et
maud olivier ferrand hier dans
l'hémicycle le ministre de la santé l'a
rappelé ce projet de loi il permettra à
l'exécutif de maintenir l' usage du pass
sanitaire ou de déclencher à l'état
d'urgence jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 si la
situation l'exigé mais la perspective
d'allègement du pass demeure est celle
ci sera examiné à la mi-novembre pour
autant hier l'exécutif a dû faire face à
de nombreuses accusations de la part des
oppositions face aux critiques le groupe
mrm a déposé un amendement qui prévoit
la possibilité pour l'exécutif de
recourir à un usage du pass en prenant
en compte un certain nombre de critères
et donc en justifiant son utilisation
parmi ces critères le taux de
vaccination d'incidence ou par exemple
de saturation des lits de réanimation
les niveaux eux doivent encore être
définis notez aussi à cet amendement a
déposé par le député thierry michel
visant à donner à la possibilité aux
employeurs qui le souhaitent de recourir
au pass sanitaire du côté de la
troisième dose olivier vers ans a
souligné hier son importance pour les
plus de 65 ans et les plus fragiles à
terme la validité du pass sanitaires
pourraient être conditionnées à
l'injection de cette troisième dose pour
cette catégorie de la population une
possibilité selon le porte parole du
gouvernement et des débats qui vont donc
se poursuivre estelle et ce alors que le
pays entre dans la saison froide et que
les spécialistes guettent les signes
avant coureurs d'un possible redémarrage
de l'épidémie
exactement et même si l'amélioration se
poursuit santé publique france a par
exemple relevé une baisse moins marquée
des indicateurs épidémiologique la
semaine du 4 octobre par rapport à la
semaine précédente une épidémie qui
regagne du terrain mais c'est très léger
voilà comment le porte parole du
gouvernement a résumé la situation
sanitaire du pays sur rtl gabriela
talent qui a tout de même lancé un appel
à la vigilance
merci beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
précisions estelle farges en direct
devant l'assemblée nationale à paris